hello and welcome to this video click i
am cortex 408 ego our beauty book
something very tricky name so what do we
get
no someone actually dares to play d5
yeah you see too much of III and c3 in
really ok I think like a g6 in this
position yeah that's a quite risky
opening really for black you you have so
many you play so many moves with the
Queen ed term yeah it can be very risky
but you get an unbalance to the ring
that sets
absolutely absolutely sure okay hmm I
don't want to little bit going to 94 the
tempo I also want to go to c7 yeah not
good
while my development is completely bad
here now it is very risky
look c128 that looks extremely shaky
extremely shaking my time surviving the
next couple of moves I mean really okay
shape but actually doing that is
stressful Italy said I'm attacking b2m
if you place like Quincy to a castle and
a six is hanging so it's all very cheeky
like this play it if it works out it
works not funny so I have to I have to
get out here again if he takes that
before now I can take a 6 ok so it
covers that so actually I should
probably cover before them 94 25 is not
oh then it's gotta okay 5 hmm okay Oh
laughs oh good god I didn't did not
really appreciate UK 5 okay this okay 5
also has some coordination issues
okay well I can take b2 here right I
have absolutely no development but I can
take that okay well I can check now now
that that should be fine
it should be fine for me all this stuff
here doesn't do all that much right to
c5 will be really nice yeah now I'm
winning now basically I think it's a
very good position oh I didn't see this
more coming that might be strong but if
I take and go here I take a six and nine
p3 is a big threat might be three is a
big threat he wants to play with Knight
to g5 I guess that must be the idea
my lats and it's still very a very
substantial fork so I can also check 85
and is that better
no I think this is good
and now we are 95 isn't annoying move
really
yeah after the temple I have to check
this I actually win the base to win this
piece he has no good King wolf that took
me just yeah tough tough position this
dis opening is always extremely
unbalanced you have all those clean
moves that it looks really really
strange but difficult difficult to
really get something substantial yeah
any less completely unfazed and says
equal yeah it doesn't even like that for
item no it doesn't really need too much
a success hanging so I mean if you look
at the development it's not that bad he
still needs a bishop moving castles
after that yeah okay I can actually play
this six bits this I wanted to spawn
three takes before it's good though now
I'm not better than allowing this you
know black is just this is winning him
yeah it's a very very tricky opening
that I feel is very good for black if
you want to play for win stream the
unbalanced okay guys thanks for watching